the seeds of discontent now in full
bloom
picket lines are popping up with
increasing frequency this time its
University lecturers
they are fighting for higher pay Rises
at a time when record inflation is
tearing down their living standards real
pay has gone down over 25 for lecturers
we're struggling we live in London we
teach in London and to survive we need a
we need a pay rise we have worked so
hard during Kobe you know to support our
students and we are not seeing a
paradise now industrial relations are at
their most fractious since 1989 as pay
growth continues to slip behind
inflation official figures show wages in
the public sector grew by 4.2 percent in
the three months to December compared to
the previous year
for private sector workers the figure
was 7.3 percent but they amount to a pay
cut when you consider that inflation is
running at 10.5 percent
from lecturers and teachers to railway
and postal workers the clamor for pay
Rises is growing as workers reject real
terms pay cuts
but employers are holding their nerve
with the economy heading into recession
redundancies are already rising and the
unemployment rate is expected to tick up
all of this in theory should dampen the
pressure on wage growth in the economy
24 000 people were made redundant during
the last three months while the ratio of
unemployed people to vacancies increased
economists believe competition for jobs
will get fiercer as the economic Outlook
deteriorates I'd definitely be looking
at that one k Ballard is one of those
struggling to find work the Lorry driver
from East London says good opportunities
are few and far between I'm looking like
part-time at the moment to ease myself
back into the market female
old
they'll use any excuse not to implore
you
when it comes to Industrial action no
side is showing signs of backing down
but with the unemployment due to rise
the momentum Behind These strikes May
soon start to slow
as the balance of power shifts from
workers back to employers
government Sky News